The next thing you can do is you can co-locate.
Basically, this means buying space
in a rack in a data center.
So, you still buy your own machines and
you install them in this data center
or maybe you buy a whole rack or you buy a
whole cage but basically a lot of websites do this.
The biggest ones have their own data centers.
The biggest reason you do this is
you have control over the machines.
You can build whatever machines you want,
configure them however you want,
and wire them together however you want.
They're your machines, and you're renting the space.
Generally, you pay for things like rent to have your
space, and then you pay for power and bandwidth.
You pay for 30 amps or 60 amps to
power a couple of machines in a rack,
or you may pay for many more to
have a whole cage of machines
and you pay for how much bandwidth to use.
You maybe only need 10 megs a second
or maybe you need 10 gigs.
It all depends and you have control over all of this.
Downside is there's a high amount of work. You
have to actually administer these machines.
You have to install software.
You have to maintain them.
If they break, you have to replace them.
It's a lot of effort.
So, if you're not good at sysadmining--system administration--doing all that sort of thing
colocation is a tough option.
If you like doing that sort of thing, you can
save some money by co-locating
or if you're a big website with highly specialized
needs, data centers are the way to go.
Few large websites don't control their own machines.